en ocasiones la idea de que no hay
artista qatarí entonces
y luego
bueno yo teníamos esa ideología sí como
siempre
y yo
al aire
la toma del caballo se monte
al baile pues mi hermana es
no podemos ni regresar salvarlo
bueno
la historia
de nuevo en la literatura que se llama
el camino
en este caso el en dónde termina
sí
el espacio
no es crear historias
[Música]
el aire
diane lane
en mi caso pues tienes que 123 generando
una empresa
[Música]
no importa lo que digan yo voy a él
y bueno
yo siento que los sueños de no ser
es una gata alguna enfermedad o debes
hacer algo
[Música]
de todos los universos diferentes
y qué
sin embargo
gente
en una
y el miedo
[Música]
y puedes utilizarlo para llegar muy
lejos
a mi padre
el orden limpieza cuidado y todo eso
ah
[Música]
también vas a encontrar algo digo yo he
encontrado gente que me ha apoyado a
partir de mis amigos
e
gracias
y entonces
por qué por qué por qué por qué cosas
y hoy
me va de los milagros
entonces hazlo
sin embargo como aprender cosas sin
problemas
cabanillas
tus amigos maestros
bueno
tenemos problemas para entrar aquí mismo
a veces tienes problemas
muchas cosas
bueno
[Música]
pero eso no es
se utiliza
y bien dada la suprema
i
no teníamos la experiencia lugar no
teníamos
pues de un día
sin embargo tenía una pasión teníamos de
hacer las cosas y si nos lo vamos a
hacer vamos a seguir creciendo y no
dormíamos no dormíamos si estábamos
trabajando pero lograron terminada la
película
[Música]
y
sin embargo esa satisfacción es esa
sensación sin tener los conocimientos y
la experiencia
y él
[Música]
diseñador y para eso
tuvimos muchas oportunidades de trabajo
con estas ideas no veamos llegamos a
donde estamos ahorita
y
tal vez
hacer
[Música]
aquellos la experiencia triste no hay
vuelta atrás entonces viene la parte de
atrás
es el personaje
seguimos avanzando
las restricciones en el camino del ebro
si vamos a resurgir
y bien
[Música]
qué es lo que hacemos
sin embargo tenemos miedos
lo que les daba de alegre
yo creo
[Música]
en los resultados
y bueno él estuvo comentando
pues trabajando y esforzándose día a día
aprendiendo cosas yo también es lo mismo
así como vendiendo por sociedad
y algún día vamos a lograr que ustedes